hey guys Ryan the mother [ __ ] right
now you might be asking yourself there's
like a hair of mine what the [ __ ] it
won't go away they might be asking
yourself why is Ryan especially cocky
today more than he normally is it's
because they subscriber a man named the
Evan Jay show forgot your real name
total douche bag right now for not
knowing your real name dude I'm assuming
it 7 j ok so this homeboy I'm calling
him home boy because he's black black
black and I'm a total racist I just
thought I could get away with it this
time this dude what he did is he did a
reaction to one of my trailer reactions
that dude is [ __ ] awesome I feel
honored I feel like really good this is
that like a compliment in so many ways
gonna suck your dick one day 'even Jake
it's gonna be one hell of a show anyway
right now the universe is gonna explode
I will be reacting to Evan Jay reacting
to be reacting reacting and then one day
everyone will record a reaction to me
anyway let's check this out what's going
on you guys Evan j here whoa I'm going
to talk about this funny very very funny
youtube channel called the real rejects
I'm sorry I'm wearing hat because my
hair is messy I'm not go show haha it's
okay Evan any way to guy that runs the
channel his name is ryan right guy
should subscribe to this guy this guy's
funny and his friends um Jerry and um um
what's good I'm Sally someone know where
that is this is so cool so you want Mike
emphasis is hilarious oh wow the olden
days and we're filming yes I mean we're
not gonna read you this opening you see
the sense of humor just gonna have um
and this is some code called um no
actually the is a film a short film it's
called um
I love this it's an easy he's a cool fan
and Valentine's Day remember I just
named it it's the one that Sally made
its really really funny check out this
is cool dude
it's actually the st. Patrick's Day
short film but it's okay it's okay what
matters is where your heart is that my
bad that's the wrong film hi knowledged
it's called how to get lucky that part
we're right where know where Sally comes
in the room and Ryan has the ax dapper
that part killed me that was too funny
anyway subscribe to them the veal
rejects will reject som REE L not
r.e.a.l thank you so much he knows how
clever we are like that you're going to
enjoy our videos is really funny they do
trailer reactions in our short films it
yeah that's pretty much it and movie
reviews if you're watching this I'm big
fan please give me a shadow over you're
getting one but anyway just watch this
video's really Evan jay chou please oh
wait you are master piece wow dude I'm
sweating out of joy I've been sweating a
lot these videos anyway dude yeah that
feels really good where are you from
because I saw your face and I was like
yo what up dawg and then I heard you
talking I'm like I don't think he's that
kind of black guy this is really cool
cuz a few episodes ago I was saying like
I want more black friends you know I
would love cuz you just look cooler when
you're with a black person for some
reason the other really cool and oh we
should have a black chick on this show
dude we need a black chick to come on
this program along with a blonde I don't
know any blondes no I don't know any
belongs Rick craigslist comes in handy I
almost hooked up with a black girl from
craigslist actually it would have been
the first black girl ever hooked up with
didn't go through she wanted to have a
threesome with another man and I was
like I don't know
about that [ __ ] should have done it be
if you're new to the channel subscribe
see we're a family here and the devil's
the outside world they do things that
disobey the Lord Jesus so they got to be
murdered but yes Evan J show you the man
homie and I'm gonna use your video
because this is how it is gonna shout
out to you but I want to give shoutouts
to other people as well real fast hope
that's okay with you Evan j Trevin
alexander it's his birthday today happy
[ __ ] birthday buddy hope you get your
dicks up bicknell 67 this guy comments a
lot thank you for commenting my friend
you wanted to shout out to fears the
shell without Xia Spidey I watched a
trailer well a commercial for eV and EV
a-- something like that of spider-man
and you apparently was the only one who
requested this and he may be right about
that so I wanted to say thank you gia
Spidey has logan your name again sorry
but thank you cuz I like that commercial
just so you know if I didn't mention you
on a video that just means I don't care
about you no I'm just [ __ ] with you I
go in like order I just you know right
down everyone who wants a shout out or
I'm like this person I want to shout out
to them I basically just go in order
some people say you you forgot about me
Ryan but that's not true baby come here
it's make love tonight never forget
about you and tonight you ain't gonna
forget about this [ __ ]